hey leute was klappt herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ja es ist grad um
gelogen weil wieder 20 57 bin gerade
nach hause gekommen
und ja keine ahnung ich bin zwar ultra
müde ich sehe auch heftig müde aus ich
habe mir einfach eine kappe aufgesetzt
bei meiner heraus irgendwie keine habe
also komische habe ist wahrscheinlich
legal auf jeden fall
es soll halt kurz ich wollte es halt ich
wollte halt ehrlich ein video zu drehen
weil es ist so eine sache sodass checke
ich nicht und da sieht man mal sowas
youtube mit irgendwelchen menschen macht
und keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
vielleicht ist da auch unnötig das in
die öffentlichkeit zu ziehen
aber meiner meinung nach das ist auch
verdient wirklich so also keiner ich
weiß gar nicht was euer reaktion auf
diesen youtuber dann sind aber ehrlich
es kann man ich fange einfach weil ich
jetzt hier durch kurz was ich weiß nicht
ob es richtig oder falsch ist das jetzt
zu sagen aber keine ahnung muss einfach
mal kurz raus das ist regt mich einfach
auf ganz ehrlich so das hätte ich sie
niemals erwartet
und das ist halt schon so ein bisschen
schade für mich auf jeden fall
es geht halt um guten kollegen von mir
eigentlich also hedge habe ich ja viele
videos mitgemacht und das ding war halt
so
er wollte halt auch mit youtube anfang
und ich weiß wo er kann dazu er ist halt
so eine persönlichkeit so leute zu
unterhalten kann der halt und ich hab
mir mal die ich kenne ihn schon länger
habe ihn damals kennengelernt und hab
ich halt gesagt gemacht wir machen was
zusammen ich helfe ein bisschen am
anfang hab mir auch wirklich so geholfen
ich habe mir wirklich von anfang an als
1.000 abonnenten hat keine ahnung habe
ich mit dem videos gemacht dass er halt
ein bisschen
starthilfe hat oder so weil es sich ja
wirklich mühe gibt und er gibt es ja
auch immer noch in mir das würde ich
auch gar nicht hinterfragen eine weitere
sache ist vielleicht noch richtig war
jetzt einfach drauflos keine ahnung
keine katzen sonst was er ist halt auch
in dem gleich netzwerk wie ich und das
ding war deshalb wegen mir da
reingekommen so ich habe ihn halt so
dazu gebracht ja okay da rein ich habe
ihm so geholfen da rein zu kommen und so
weiter weil es halt wirklich cooles da
und er fühlt sich auch da wurden diesem
netzwerk ist ein satz oder ich habe
letztens mal mit hingenommen dahin auf
jeden fall waren sondern halt zusammen
dort so alles cool ich verstehe mich
auch mit einläuten cool andere user aus
dem netzwerk und er war dann so zwei
tage später auch noch mal da hat mich
auch persönlich voll gefreut dass er
dann noch immerhin fährt so okay leute
jetzt weiß ich schon wieder nicht wo ich
weiß es wie gesagt ziemlich spät auf
jeden fall erwarten halt bei bei meinem
netzwerk und hat mit ein paar leuten die
ich halt auch schon länger kenne und so
und das ding ist halt man erfährt so
über die leute die eigentlich gar nichts
mit ihm zu tun haben so im hintergrund
dass die haben sich jetzt auch so
gefragt hey keinen sind und rees mit dem
videos aber lässt das dann im rücken so
iris krass zu bannen ich habe da
wirklich so du bist komische dinge
gehört die gar keinen sinn ergeben die
auch nicht hierher gehören aber so was
halt wie gesagt so man wenn ich ein
video mit dem dreh so ich kenne ich
schon länger so wir sind immer voll cool
zusammen wenn man sagt man ist halt cool
wie gesagt und man erwartet mich von
solchen personen dass ich dann halt so
was sagen so und keine ahnung ich finds
halt mega schade weil ich finde die
videos die wir zusammen
die haben halt immer bock gemacht die
wir zusammen gedreht haben die haben
halt immer bock gemacht genau und ich
habe hier noch versuche darauf
anzusprechen
keine ahnung ich bekomme keine antwort
derzeit so und das regt mich halt schon
auf das dass man dann ja und dann finde
ich es halt wirklich so schade so jetzt
habe ich mich schon wieder versprochen
auf jeden fall so klar
bei ihm läuft bei mir läuft alles gut
aber wie gesagt er darf wirklich nicht
vergessen warum das so ist da gab es
viele faktoren und so und und das ist
jetzt wirklich so ein punkt da denke ich
mir sicher denken nur weil du 160.000
wie viele es hat bist bist du was
besseres oder soweit bei der glatt läuft
vergiss nicht jeder ist so ein mensch
und du musst dich irgendeinen scheiß
erzählen so ehrlich so wenn du das jetzt
hieß dann freut mich das ding ist alles
cool mir ist es egal wir brauchen nichts
mehr zusammen drehen alles cool ich
finds halt nur scheiße dass du so was
erzählt schmerzlich beantwortest was ist
das bitte da hat es auch verdient dass
ich sie wieder drüber machen klar die
einen werden jetzt sagen das sieht man
doch nicht in die öffentlichkeit das
kennt man privat ganz ehrlich
interessiert mich überhaupt ich mach's
wie ich bock hab so erlaubt auch wieder
bock hat dann kann ich auch videos
machen wie ich bock habe wo ich lange
wie ich bei katja das sehen jetzt
vielleicht 1000 wahrscheinlich wird das
was die piste ist ja immer total geheilt
ist mir auch egal
ihr könnt schreibt was ihr wollt ihr
könnt sie beschreiben was ihr wollt ich
bin halt scheiße weil ich euch sagen ich
hab ein video zu machen interessiert
mich gar nicht vertragen hatte
wir sehen uns morgen denke ich wieder
beim neuen video da kommt dann wieder
was normal ist oder so hieß
ich kenne sie schlafe ich bin müde